la primera Cumbre iberoamericana se
celebró en el 1991 y tenía un propósito
muy claro reforzar los vínculos
históricos entre los países de la
Península ibérica y los latinoamericanos
la idea fue de España y su principal
Aliado para lanzar el proyecto México y
las bases que quisieron establecer
fueron muy amplias promocionar la
cooperación y desarrollo de todos los
países miembro
debemos ser capaces de establecer desde
los más profundos criterios de humanidad
hospitalidad y solidaridad un modelo
iberoamericano pero en estos 22 años
Cuál ha sido la efectividad real de esta
Cumbre antes anualmente y desde 2014
cada dos años los jefes de estado
cancilleres se reúnen para abordar
problemáticas comunes y negociaciones
comerciales o inversiones y más que un
espacio para la toma de decisiones la
Cumbre es un espacio para el diálogo tan
importante como el plan de rescate fina
nciero será el plan de rescate social
por eso Muchos critican su utilidad por
la falta de acuerdos vinculantes tras
las reuniones y porque los temas más
polémicos como la crisis migratoria en
el continente americano o los gobiernos
autoritarios como el de Nicaragua suelen
quedar afuera de la agenda
Esta es la pregunta que debemos hacernos
al inicio de la decimosexta Cumbre
iberoamericana
[Música]
es necesario una mayor es necesario una
determinación más firme por nuestra
parte cuando pasemos de La retórica a la
acción y justo esa falta de acción es lo
que muchos critican España país fundador
ha utilizado este espacio como vía de
conexión con los países latinoamericanos
en su agenda de relaciones exteriores
con quien comparte historia cultura y
costumbres y aunque la nación europea ha
estado distanciada de América Latina en
muchas ocasiones este año su peso es
especial por qué con su presidencia en
el consejo de la Unión Europea podría
servir de interlocutor entre América
Latina y Europa y acercarla al viejo
continente tras años de relaciones
oxidadas algo que sería un motor para el
desarrollo en la región latinoamericana